Does it really make sense to listen to
sad music when you're sad?
Wouldn't it make you sadder? You think it
would,
but science says otherwise.
Howdy y'all. Trace here for Dnews. We've
talked a lot about music over last year.
How robots are kicking out the jams, how
music affects your brain,
and how your brain works when you're
rapping. Music is an integral part of
the human experience. But what is it
about sad music
that we like so much? When you're down, do
you listen to something that matches
your mood? If music is the universal
language of emotion, then we're gonna
need a universal translator
for sad music to really get it. If you're
listening in the West you probably
associate sad music with minor key
tonality.
If you're not exactly familiar with what
that means, the Exploratorium in San
Francisco provided some nice
examples. So listen to this, Western music
has major keys
and minor keys.
A study in the frontiers of auditory
cognitive neuroscience explores music
not as entertainment but as a language
equal or maybe even superior to spoken
languages. Their example is new borns.
As they're hearing speech for the first
time, it's rythm in vocal performance
rather than processing it as language.
To nonverbal babies, speech is kinda like
music. The question is,
what makes us think that music is sad
or happy?
It's all in the culture man. We learn as
we grow to feel sad when we listen to certain
songs.
We grow up associating sad cellos with
death and violins that are screeching with
horror.
It's the same with major and minor modes.
In other cultures major and minor modes don't
necessarily
mean the same thing they do in the West,
which is why we need to kinda understand
what's sad music is before we can
specifically study.
Another study in frontiers of emotion
science look specifically at music and
sadness. Sadness is described in the study
as
negative and unpleasant psychology of emotion.
And when we hear it our brain processes
it through our cultural lens.
The scientists hypothesized, because of our
cultural learnings, sad music
would make us sad. But they were wrong.
Instead when we listen to sad music our brain
knows it's a cultural expression of
sadness.
But realizes that it's not personal
And we interpret that as pleasure. This
is because it turns out there are two
kinds of emotions. Felt emotion as in,
"I feel sad," and perceived emotion as in,
"That is sad, but it's not me."
Put another way, if a partner breaks up with
you, you're like
bummed out.
Like really bummed out. It is
inside of you. You feel it.
But when you listen to Otis Redding singing
about how sad he is, you actually end up feeling
kinda happy.
It's tugging at your heart strings, but
your brain makes a distinction.
It knows you're not actually sad and thus
you
get pleasure from listening to it. Fantastically
this
also works when you're actually sad.
The music still gives you pleasure and
might even help you feel better in the
long run.
So next time you listen to that
emo song because it's a rainy day,
relish it man. Your brain comprehends that
you are happy. That you are not
actually sad.
So song do you listen to when you're down?
Let's make the saddest playlist ever.